[Music]
imagine an ecosystem made entirely of
autonomous machines where every
ecological niche is filled by an
artificial organism in the video game
horizon zero dawn a global calamity has
led to a version of planet earth
inhabited by animal mimicking machines
from mighty herbivores to deadly
predators while these synthetic
creatures might not be biological their
fascinating interactions unique
behavioral patterns and hidden
intricacies make them worthy of study
the story takes place thousands of years
in the future but a little thing like
the flow of time isn't going to stop
this archivist from doing his field work
so for this entry into the archive i'll
lead us on another documentary style
expedition investigating the artificial
biology of these intriguing machines and
revealing what animal roles they fill
we'll need though to stay alert there
are constant dangers in this environment
now let's leap forward in time and
discover an ecosystem
of metal and wire
beginning in the safety of a region
known as the embrace we find a
picturesque landscape that shows little
signs of a planet-wide calamity across
much of the land wounds of old have long
since healed although this reborn earth
is much changed from the peak of human
civilization
small populations of human
hunter-gatherers still inhabit this land
though most live within meager
settlements ever fearful of the strange
metal creatures that roam the woods
whose function they have long forgotten
setting out into the wilderness i find
that some organic animal life does still
persist in the shifting underbrush but
the roles they fill are small and
infrequent for this is no longer their
world
peering out from the grass i spot a
being roughly the size of a horse
our first machine
this is a strider a basic type of
synthetic creature that fills the
function of a herbivore like organic
herbivores striders spend much of their
time quietly grazing in small herds
moving from one patch of grass to
another yet what use does a machine have
for grass
the answer lies in a small canister
located between the strider's haunches
this container is filled with a green
liquid called blaze a type of biofuel
synthesized from plants that is
foundational to the artificial ecosystem
of this world
striders or machines that convert grass
into fuel much like how any living
herbivore essentially uses vegetation to
power their bodies striders also bring
blaze back to autonomous factories
called cauldrons which continue to
repair and replace machines long after
being forgotten yet this energy source
also makes striders a target for human
hunter gatherers this means that like
most herbivores a strider's life is one
of constant vigilance when a threat
looms their optical sensors turn an
uneasy orange skittish by nature the
strider's first instinct when human
hunters are near is to run and like
horses when the herd takes off they can
move with breathtaking speed with all
four legs pumping they can easily outrun
most dangers only slowing when the coast
is clear not wanting to disturb these
creatures i try to stay out of sight
but that is easier said than done
regarding the outskirts of the herd is a
new type of machine
this is a watcher and they make
fieldwork a challenge
these small bipedal beings spend their
existence tirelessly patrolling the
perimeter of the strider herd and
precious little slips past their optical
sensors unnoticed animals serving as
lookouts isn't unheard of in nature with
the designated century a key role in
meerkat society but this sort of
coordination between two species so to
speak is something unique to machines by
warning the striders of imminent danger
watchers are almost like living security
cameras well living in a sense
and they also play the role of bodyguard
with surprising speed watchers can
launch themselves into a flying kick
it's an impressive if unwieldy strategy
yet watchers will fight to the very end
while the strider herd flees and
unfortunately one has spotted me
launching into their signature kick a
watcher misses my head and suffers a
pretty serious wipeout stumbling to
their feet they seem rattled but
unharmed only their pride is bruised
not wanting to be insensitive i give my
unsuccessful assailant the slip going
forwards i'll have to be more careful as
there are far more dangerous things than
watchers in this world of machines
to the north of the embrace my path
takes me to a region strewn with the
scars of civilization the crumbling
remnants of buildings have been all but
swallowed up by the steady encroachment
of nature
yet even after a thousand years a quiet
melancholy still clings to this site
yet there are machines in this broken
unpredictable landscape the deer like
grazers are adaptable enough to brave
this region native to the rolling fields
beyond the ruins outskirts razors
possess a pair of metallic antler-like
structures that serve a curious function
on the ends of these structures are a
set of rotor blades which the grazers
use to shred grass and dirt like
sentient lawn mowers with this unusual
setup grazers can consume plant matter
faster than any other machine and like
deer where there is one grazer there are
invariably others a herd of grazers with
all their heads shoved in the dirt is an
odd sight indeed yet grazers don't have
time to worry about their image as with
four canisters of biofuel to fill
they're always on the move but when a
grazer feels threatened their antlers
have another function when i move too
close to one grazer the machine takes a
fearsome swipe at me a narrow miss as
leith herbivore analogs grazers aren't
built for combat and so this unit
scampers away once i stand my ground
journeying deeper into the city ruins i
find the feeling of desolation grows
in this graveyard of humanity i sense
something is lurking just out of sight
a terrifying machine haunts this
landscape
a sawtooth rippling with synthetic
muscle this cat-like hunter is the
equivalent of an apex predator in the
machine ecosystem their metal jaws come
equipped with a pair of curved serrated
spikes which resemble the formidable
fangs of the largest saber-toothed cats
there are rumors among the local humans
that the cauldrons have been making
larger and more dangerous machines in
recent years and looking at the sawtooth
i don't doubt it a machine this large
might not seem capable of great speed
yet when a sawtooth catches a target in
the open they can move with incredible
agility aside from their fangs sawtooths
also possess claws powerful enough to
shred through the metal of these ruins
trying to fight or run from a sawtooth
is futile the only way i'll live to
archive another day is if i avoid the
sawtooth altogether these ruins are
their domain now and the time has come
to make my exit
as the machines continue to nurture the
ecosystem nature will eventually reclaim
this region entirely leaving behind no
trace of the people who lived here even
monuments of metal and stone can't last
forever
venturing to the west i find a vast
scrub land baking in the sweltering rays
of the rising sun yet machines have
conquered this unforgiving environment
as well with unique adaptations to brave
the arid region these are long legs
machines with a tall bird-like
appearance like the ostriches of today
long legs are stuck on the ground unable
to take flight yet through my
observations i found that long legs have
a hidden ability mounted on their chest
are two bulbous sacs that resemble
external lungs these artificial sacs are
in fact sonic amplifiers when a long leg
feels threatened they can unleash a
booming concussive sound wave so
powerful it sends particulates flying
for this reason i'd recommend wearing
serious ear protection when observing
long legs up close
aside from their sound waves long legs
are also capable of alarming bursts of
speed
they'll even leap into astonishing
flying kicks which look both beautiful
and frankly absurd
all in all these unusual machines are
better left alone
my intuition takes me northwards where i
find a ruined landscape of twisted metal
this rusted necropolis is a vast
scrapyard the skeletal remains of human
civilization and a unique kind of
machine has come to pick these metal
bones clean
prowling in the shadows of the junkyard
are packs of scrappers small but deadly
scrappers rule over this ruined kingdom
with their humped posture and clawed
feet scrappers resemble the skulking
forms of hyenas and like hyenas
scrappers can be uncommonly vicious yet
there is another side to these seemingly
simple terrors
scrapper jaws are composed of four
unique circular grinders but these jaws
aren't just for hunting true to their
name scrappers use their curious mouths
to recycle metal resources in grinding
down salvage piles and the bodies of
inactive machines the scrappers gather
materials that can be used in the
construction of more synthetic life and
so these machines fill a role similar to
scavengers in this ecosystem of metal
and improve the health of the
environment yet scrappers aren't purely
altruistic if i were to be spotted by
one they would waste no time in trying
to recycle me for any non-machines this
metal cemetery is a dangerous place
amid the dry badlands the flow of rivers
creates isolated pockets of vegetation
and patrolling the rare wetlands are
one-of-a-kind machines
shell walkers
these scuttling oddities move on six
stout legs and can brave both wet and
dry terrain and unlike all other types
of machines i've observed so far shell
walkers double as transport vehicles a
class dedicated to ferrying materials
back to cauldrons they carry their
quarry in hexagonal cargo containers on
their back which they swap regularly
with their ever-changing shells a shell
walker's lifestyle mirrors that of a
hermit crab
if you ask me a futuristic robot
converging on a crab makes complete
sense as crabs are the pinnacle of
evolution and shellwalkers will defend
their cargo to the end on their front
side shellwalkers possess two powerful
arms one tipped with a formidable claw
and the other with a mysterious circular
disc upon moving closer i discover this
is some form of energy shield generator
that the shellwalkers can deploy to
protect their left side while they
attack with their right while energy
shields are certainly unique to machines
this sort of asymmetrical defensive
setup can also be found in the natural
world fiddler crabs are armed with one
claw that is significantly larger than
the other which they use to fight over
burrows with their versatile crab like
body shell walkers are well equipped to
traverse this unpredictable world
speaking of which as i venture into the
western wastes the climate becomes even
harsher rusting under the afternoon sun
are the remains of a great satellite
array before the world fell to ruin
these dishes might have been for
communication hurtling signals out to
the stars yet now these ruins send no
messages save a silent reminder that
nothing lasts forever and seemingly on
cue
circling overhead are what appear to be
a flock of vultures a universal omen of
grim tidings yet like most creatures in
this land these foragers are made of
metal i've entered into the territory of
glinthawks
these aerial machines keep a grim vigil
over this stretch of the badlands their
exceptionally keen eyesight means that
little slips through this region without
their notice yet despite their fearsome
appearance glinthawks play an important
role in the machine biosphere wherever
the carcasses of non-functional machines
can be found a glinthawk is sure to be
nearby breaking down the metal for
resources in a manner similar to a
scrapper like modern vultures glinthawks
are obligate scavengers breaking down
the parts others leave behind it's an
unsettling profession but someone has to
do it as long as the flock is distracted
with their salvage duties i should be
able to pass through this area if i do
so cautiously yet one glinthawk seems to
have grown wise to my presence in a
surprising turn the metal fiend sends
volley after volley of freezing liquid
my way
this is actually the glinthawk's coolant
which they can jettison from their
bodies as a kind of chemical defense
fleeing across the desert i find that
this glinthawk thankfully doesn't seem
interested in an extended chase
if i don't wish to be claimed by this
land myself i need to find a way to
escape this heat a cool dip in the water
seems promising except this river is
occupied swimming just under the surface
is a huge snapmaw these imposing
machines are forced to be reckoned with
both in water and on land everything
from their gate to their anatomy to
their general behavior closely mirrors
that of a crocodile yet if the jaws of
crocodiles weren't frightening enough
the lower mandible of the snapmaw is
actually a chainsaw-like blade with a
system of small grinders at its base
if one strays too close to the water's
edge it's over in an instant
keeping my distance from the riverbank
however i notice snapmaws actually spend
most of their time basking in the sun's
rays like many so-called cold-blooded
animals crocodiles sun themselves to
increase their body temperature yet what
reason might a machine have for regular
sunbathing the answer lies in the rows
of solar panels lining the snapmaw's
back
this clever energy gathering array means
that even when a snapmaw seems to be
inactive they are actually gaining the
power needed for their daily movements
in this land even a machine as menacing
as a snapmaw has hidden intricacies
with a swim seeming unwise i escape the
heat with a change in the elevation
throughout the waste isolated plateaus
rise so high their peaks are crowned
with snow
in these frigid microclimates the
strange landscapes are home to even
stranger machines trudging through the
snow is a bizarre procession of freeze
bellowbacks these hearty slow-moving
machines are well acclimated to the
world of ice and snow with their sloped
posture billowbacks subtly echo the body
plan of theropod dinosaurs like baryonyx
as another type of transport machine
freeze bellowbacks carry large reserves
of coolant and hefty cargo sacks on
their back and four smaller sacks under
their neck when perturbed freeze
bellowbacks will spray a high pressure
stream of coolant from their nozzle it's
a devastating and effective defense
mechanism even if it looks a bit like
sneezing in these low temperatures a
blast of coolant can be deadly i think
it's best to let the bellowback
procession pass on by
hiking down to the base of the snowy
mesa i'm drawn to the sound of
thundering footsteps
creeping closer i stumble into the midst
of a herd of giants these are behemoths
beasts that look like they could carry
the weight of a mountain or smash their
way through one like the largest rhinos
or elephants behemoths or the megafauna
of the environment of machines the
mightiest of the transport class their
belly has a large space into which a
circular cargo container is locked into
place by clamps and like all transport
machines behemoths are fiercely
protective when it comes to their cargo
in awe i watch from a distance as a
behemoth levitates a ring of boulders
using anti-gravity technology then slams
them down with a force so great it
shakes the valley this mysterious power
made possible through a forgotten
technology makes the behemoths an
insurmountable force
while they typically use this power to
gather minerals and other materials for
transport if i'm spotted these giants
won't hesitate to unleash their crushing
force to end my expedition prematurely
worrying as such an outcome might be i
can't help but stay transfixed by the
strength of these beings in time however
the convoy lumbers on continuing their
steady march across the valley
traveling as far west as i dare venture
i reach a region where the greatest
terror of the machine world dwells
no amount of prior observation prepares
me for the sight that is the thunderjaw
bristling with advanced weaponry from
tip to tail the thunderjaw is a bringer
of pure dread
in terms of size and sheer might they
represent a strength not seen in this
region since the tyrannosaurus rex some
90 million years ago and unlike most
machines this metal super predator's
sole function is combat from their jaws
an array of cannons bring destruction
like the breath of a dragon on their
hips are a pair of disc launchers which
rain down fire and smoke from above even
without their futuristic weaponry a
thunderjaw is still more than capable of
dispatching any threat with their
massive tail perhaps the greatest weapon
of all the further i stay from this
machine the better yet in the glow of
the setting sun even a thunderjaw can
look majestic without a visible target
thunderjaws behave like most any animal
plotting around their environment at a
leisurely pace while i watched the
thunderjaw pass on
i can't help but wonder what this land
might be like if machines and humans
weren't so diametrically opposed
but my journey is not over yet at the
edge of a shimmering lake footsteps echo
over the water so loud the entire land
seems to tremble in anticipation
overhead the largest machine i've ever
seen appears to eclipse the very sun
this moving landmark is a tall neck they
can be found across many different
environments although their numbers are
scarce
unlike every other machine i've
documented today these beings are in no
way distrustful of humans with their
silhouette and gate talmax seems
somewhere between a giraffe and the
largest sauropod dinosaurs the strange
disc that functions like the tallneck's
head serves as a communications array
sending information to and from the
other machines in this way the solitary
tallnecks act as the unofficial hubs of
the machine ecosystems it's a vital yet
seemingly lonely purpose as the
tallnecks spend their existence walking
in an eternal loop never thanked for
their vital contribution to the machine
biosphere perhaps the tallnecks are
oblivious to their surroundings or
perhaps they get lonesome on their
isolated march
though i'm well aware i'm likely
projecting my own emotions onto the
tallnecks i decide to stay with the
beasts as long as i am able after all a
path can be less lonely when walked with
a friend
there's much we've uncovered about this
world of machines yet many key mysteries
remain unsolved from the dense jungles
of the south to the frozen wilds of the
far north there are a whole host of
machines i've yet to document in secrets
i've yet to uncover we'll venture
further across the world of horizon zero
dawn in part two exploring the more
bizarre and more dangerous machines in
the lost reaches of the world but for
now our journey is at an end
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support and like subscribe and hit the
notification icon to stay up to date on
all things curious
see you in the next video
you